so we've got a symbol gamma and in fact
this is the third pass we've made at
gamma we had a video on gamma and then
we made another one which we unoriginal
II called gamma reloaded so I guess even
more unoriginal II we ought to call this
one gamma revolutions gamma is this
factor which comes up all over the place
in special relativity it's due with you
know when you have distances being
squashed when things are traveling close
to the speed of light the amount they're
squashed by this factor of gamma when
time becomes dilated so time becomes
extended when something's traveling
first as close to the speed of light the
amount is extended by is by this factor
gamma so it's put a very sort of
fundamental piece of physics so
mathematically gamma this factor is
equal to 1 over square root of 1 minus V
squared over C squared so if you've got
an object or a reference frame which is
moving at speed V then its gamma factor
is this quantity here so it's equal to 1
when something's not moving at V is
equal to 0 this quantity comes out as 1
and as V goes up closest to gets closer
and closer to the speed of light gamma
gets bigger and bigger well one of the
things I said in probably the first and
the second video was actually if you
want to derive why gamma has that
particular form it's actually not that
difficult to do and so when you do that
then in the comments underneath the
video quite a lot of people say well go
on then do it do it go on so that's what
we'll do
we'll do it are you going to do math not
very hard so the hardest mass here is
Pythagoras's theorem square on the
hypotenuse is equal to the sum of the
squares on the other two side I promise
no harder than that we need to back up a
little bit and talk about special
relativity to do this the fundamental
principle in in special relativity is
that all reference frames are the same
and you can't tell if you're as long as
you're not accelerating so if you're
just moving at uniform speed or
stationary the laws of physics are
exactly the same so in a thing called an
inertial reference frame you can't tell
whether that reference frame is moving
or whether it's still you'll end up you
know if you were inside a closed box in
there whatever experiments you could do
you'll always end up with the same laws
of physics you won't be able to tell I'm
moving and that guy still or that guy's
moving and I'm still and everyone sort
of familiar with that right that
basically you know if you're on an
aeroplane the laws of physics don't
change you know if you drop something
it's you know if you spilled your coffee
it still ends up on your lap if you put
something in the microwave the microwave
oven still works on the airplane so the
laws of physics are the same if you're
moving at constant speed or if you're
section F you start accelerating then
obviously you can feel the effects of
the acceleration but as long as you're
moving at uniform speed it makes no
difference to any laws of physics at all
next part of the story is
electromagnetism which is says that you
know so going back to Maxwell at the end
of the 19th century figured out these
laws of electromagnetism and from those
he derived the speed of light the speed
of light turns out as a very simple form
that it's not in some sense a
fundamental constant if you know about
electrostatics how charges attract each
other if you know about magnetism how
magnets attracts each other then
actually you could derive what the speed
of light is so the speed of light just
comes from simple physics it's not
something that you know it's just a
made-up number it's actually you can put
in some simple physics and derive what
the speed of light it that means that
because it comes from simple physics
that means that the speed of light has
to be the same whatever reference frame
you're in because it's just come from
some simple physics and the laws of
physics at the same whatever reference
frame you enter whatever reference frame
you're in you should always see the
speed of light equal to the speed of
light now to get to the how we actually
get to gamma to do that we have to think
about clocks because clocks are one of
the things that get affected by you know
traveling close to the speed of light
the time slows down and of course if
time slowing down that means clocks can
the speed at which clocks are going is
going to change but everything is going
to change you know the speed of which
radioactive decay occurs the speed at
which you age everything is going to
change just because if they didn't all
change together then you'd know there
was something funny going on that
suddenly you know I'm only living 15
years instead of 75 years and therefore
clearly something's changed with the
laws of physics so any clock you choose
to use all other clocks have to mimic
its behavior so in special relativity
when you want to derive this equation
you can kind of set up a rather special
kind of clock a thing called a light
clock and so instead of having a
pendulum that ticks backwards and
forwards you know one tick per second
you what you actually have is you
imagine you have a light source and a
mirror and what you do is you fire out a
burst of light that goes up hits the
mirror bounces back comes back and then
you've got a little detector next to the
mirror which says whenever I detect some
light I'm going to send out another
burst of light so really you just got
little bursts of light going backwards
and forwards and it's just like a
pendulum clock in that sense that
actually sort of ticking backwards and
forwards between there and so you could
use that to measure time it's not very
sensible way to make your time but it's
a perfectly good way of measuring time
and whatever time you measure with this
light clock has to be
the same as what you've measured with
your pendulum clock or your radioactive
decay or whatever it is all right so now
we need to think about what happens to
such a clock so let me draw a picture of
it so here we've got our light source
we've got a mirror up here and we've got
a little detector here so in simple
terms all you're doing is you're firing
some light up there it bounces back and
gets detected and then you've got a
little thing that says okay whenever I
do decks of my I'll send another pulse
up and backwards and forth between these
two and we'll make this distance a
distance each and if our clocks ticking
supposing its period is tau so it does
it takes a time tau to go from there to
there and a time tau from there to go
from there to there so which of that's
analogous to like one second on a
pendulum clock as a pendulum actually
only completes a period every two
seconds right each it goes one way for a
second and then the other way for a
second so this is going to be a clock
it's probably if we make it you know the
trouble is if we wanted it to be a
second between ticks this thing would
have to be 300,000 kilometers long which
is not terribly practical so it's pretty
gonna have a shorter tick but we can
write tau if we want that H in terms of
the period is C times tau so basically
it's how to get from there today at our
to come back again just like from a
pendulum clock one second to tick one
wave one second to top and that's what
would happen you know if I have one of
these clocks sitting next to me or you
know if actually I was sitting in a
rocket and I have one of these clocks
along along for the ride with me that's
what I'd see but now imagine I'm
watching somebody in a rocket so I'm not
moving the rocket is moving relative to
me and they've got one of these clocks
and so they're watching it going
tick-tock and behaving in the way that
we've just derived here from the
perspective of the person in the rocket
they're just seeing the light going up
and down but of course the rocket from
our perspective is moving along which
means that the mirror is moving along
and the light source is moving along
which means the light instead of going
up and down like that is actually going
like this from our perspective it's
going up then coming down again so what
you draw that what's happening is from
the you know the lights are mitad at
some point and from our perspective
we're seeing this whole thing moving to
the right so actually what we see the
light doing is instead of going straight
up we see the light heading off in this
direction hitting the mirror because the
mirror is moved to the right by the time
it hits tip and then coming back down
again and of course by the time it gets
back down to the detector again the
detectors moved to the right again and
so the light instead of going straight
up and down follows a path like that so
it has further to go from our
perspective that light's gone further
but also the speed of light is
same in every reference frame and so the
lights got further to go and it's
traveling at the same speed so therefore
it takes longer to do it so one of those
ticks in our reference frame takes
longer than it did in the reference
frame in which the clock was stationary
just because the lights got further to
go and therefore it's going to take
longer to do it and we can fairly
straightforwardly mathematically figure
out how much longer it's going to take
to do it so let's go back to the picture
again for a second so this is still this
distant H it hasn't changed which we've
already said is equal to C times tau
that hasn't changed that's our ticks
that it would be the light is now moving
at the speed of light see we see it
moving and it's going to take some time
te to get where it's going so the
distance the lights traveled along here
is the speed of light times how long it
takes to get there
C times T wait and then remember this
thing is moving to the right it's moving
to the right at some speed V which means
by the time the light has got to the top
here this thing will have moved the
distance over here how far lit remove
well if it's moving it's by speed V and
it's got a time T to do it then the
distance it travels is just V times T
and this is just a right angle triangle
we've got here and so we can apply
Pythagoras's theorem which says that the
hypotenuse squared is equal to the sum
of the squares on the other to sky so CT
squared is equal to C tau squared plus
VT squared let's just write that down
we've got C squared T squared because we
squared the whole thing so it's squeeze
squared tau squared plus V squared T
squared now I need to do a little bit of
magic to rearrange this formula T
squared is equal to tau squared over 1
minus V squared C squared and then I
just take the square root of both sides
that tells me that the time I measure
and my reference frame is the time you
measure in the reference frame in which
the clock is stationary divided by
another take the square root of the bit
on the bottom one minus V squared over C
squared which is just gamma that we
defined before times tau so the factor
of gamma is how much time gets changed
by how much time gets multiplied by so
this is saying that the time we measure
TAC T is related to the time in the
reference frame in which the clock is
stationary so we'll think all the proper
time by some factor it's longer by a
factor of gamma so gamma is the amount
by which the time gets stretched
and as promised nothing harder than
Pythagoras theorem somebody approaching
the tunnel if this happens it's not
going to be such good news because
they're from their perspective the train
is longer than the tunnel which means
either the front of the train gets
chopped off or the back of the Train
gets chopped off or both